[Musik]
phoenix persönlich mein heutiger gast
ist alice schwarzer mann braucht sie
nicht näher vorzustellen jeder und jede
glaubt sie zu kennen sie sind für alle
die feministin wie anstrengend ist das
denn für sie dass sie immer mit diesem
etikett bedacht werden na ja es kommt
darauf an was man oder frau sich unter
feministinnen vorgestellt bei den
menschen die natürlich denken dass
hinter geschöpfe wie die männer fressen
und die frauen beschimpfen die nicht
total emanzipiert sind dann ist
natürlich schwierig ich bin seit 40
jahren gewohnt dass ich dieses kleine
hindern ist das da vor mir steht das
klischee immer erst mal überwinden muss
dass ich ach so sie ist auch ein mensch
sie ist ganz differenziert sie kann
lachen und so und da habe ich aber
inzwischen übung und ich verstehe das
und das mache ich und das gelingt mir
meistens auch hoffentlich auch bei ihnen
ja dass wir gleich sehen vielleicht
zunächst einmal ein kurzer blick auf den
ort wo wir hier sind das ist in köln der
frauen mediatoren da steckt so was wie
ihr lebenswerk drin geben uns noch eine
kurze einführung
ja das ist der beiden ton und der ballon
war mal der mächtigste wertung der stadt
600 jahre lang wahrzeichen der stadt
wichtiger als der dom bis der zu ende
gebaut war und seit 1994 ist da ein
archiv über die geschichte der frauen
und ihrer erfolgreichen oft
erfolgreichen oder auch nicht kämpfe für
emanzipation und gleichberechtigung drin
denn ich meine das ist unheimlich
wichtig damit die frauen nicht immer
wieder von vorne anfangen frau nahm von
wahnsinnig viel gedacht geschrieben
getan und unsere töchter und enkelinnen
sollen sich auf unsere schultern stellen
können und weiter gucken und seit
ungefähr zehn jahren ist auf einer etage
auch die ema redaktion
und wie hat er das gleiche anliegen ja
und wir schauen jetzt mal ja hier sind
wir in der öffentlichen bibliothek des
frau mega turms hier kann man stöbern
lesen studieren forschen
das ist natürlich eine goldgrube
zehntausende von büchern zeitschriften
fotos plakate
also die geschichte der frauen und ihr
kampf um gleichberechtigung schwerpunkt
auf den frauenbewegungen aber bis heute
und übrigens die neue frauenbewegung
wird in diesem jahr 50
also da wird hier ganz schön was los
sein und dass das tolle ist dass man
entdeckt wie viel schon gedacht worden
ist also da können wir dann wirklich
jetzt weitergehen das müssen wir nicht
wiederholen dürfen ja eigentlich auch
männer recherchiert frage wird oft
gestellt die dürfen sogar auch nur
kommen um zu gucken wie es hier aussieht
also es gibt hier besichtigungen müssen
sich nur anmelden da gilt das gleiche
recht für männer wie für frauen reden
wir mal über die aktuelle politische
situation 20 jahre lang wurde die cdu
von frauen geführt jetzt ist wieder ein
mann an der spitze ist das ein normaler
wechsel oder doch ein rückschlag für die
frauen
es kommt doch was ist wenn man ist wenn
er laschet ja wir werden sehen also an
sich ist ja nichts gegen zusagen nicht
also es gibt ja inzwischen diesem witz
von dem kleinen jungen der seine mutter
fragt mama können eigentlich auch männer
kanzlerin werden ich bin immer gerecht
ich finde auch männer sollten weder
kanzlerin werden können
vor allem aber die basis also als merkel
antrat hatte die cdu/csu unglaublich 35%
bundestagsabgeordnete heute sind es noch
20 weiblich weiblich also die basis muss
nachwachsen das muss strukturell
gefördert werden die eine leuchte vorne
ist war wunderbar aber die gemütlichen
ich habe hier die ema aus dem jahr 2005
angela merkel auf dem titelbild warum
sollen wir sie
frau merkel 16 jahre angela mehr geben
was als kanzlerin was hat das den frauen
gebracht
ja damals war es ja so nachdem sie
gewählt war sollte sie erstmalig
kanzlerin werden da waren sich alle
einig weil man konnte sich in dort
schreibt nicht vorstellen dass eine frau
das macht inzwischen kann man sich das
sehr gut vorstellen was hat sie erreicht
sie fragen mich jetzt speziell in bezug
auf die frauen
ich glaube nur ihre existenz diese sache
orientierte wähler weiblich kommentieren
noch die männer imitieren so ein
bisschen mädchen hab so ein bisschen
burschikos da hat sie wirklich ein role
model geschaffen und sie wird ja
international von frauen wie männern
bewundert also wenn ich im ausland bin
selbst menschen die sach kritik an
merkel haben zu diesem oder jenem punkt
beneiden uns um la merkel wie man in
frankreich sagt wir haben nur durch ihre
existenz haben glaube ich ein ganz guten
draht zu angela merkel
wie wichtig ist angela merkel das thema
frauen gleichberechtigung ich denke
gleichberechtigung ist für sie
selbstverständlich vielleicht so
selbstverständlich dass er manchmal
nicht ganz klar ist wie stark man auf
die frauen fördern muss nicht diese
physikerin aus dem osten die dachte
hauptsache ich bin süchtig so tüchtig
wie männern dann ist doch alles gut
sie musste dann auch merken dass dann
noch lange nicht alles gut ist und
frauen doppelt so tüchtig sein müssen
sie hat sich ja selber dagegen verwehrt
aber ohne sich zu distanzieren sehr
respektvoll als feministin bezeichnet zu
werden
sie sagt das kann man nicht sagen andere
feministin schwarzer die kämpfen also
das habe ich nie getan das hat sie auch
nie getan
also ich hätte mir gewünscht dass ich
mal ein bisschen mehr aber das kommt
vielleicht noch im letzten jahr da kann
sich alles erlauben noch ein bisschen
die frauen nach vorne schiebt seit 50
jahren kämpfen sie für die
gleichberechtigung der frauen wie fällt
ihre persönliche bilanz aus von mir ihre
persönlich ja sagen wir mal die bilanz
meiner generation ich hab ja zum glück
kennt mich nicht alleine
ich bin zwar an der medienfront immer
ganz vorne gewesen oder
ganz vorne aber wir sind ja doch nun
viele und letztendlich obwohl noch so
viel im argen liegt das kann man darüber
reden
letztendlich haben wir mehr erreicht als
ich nur vor 50 jahren hätte träumen
lassen also frauen sind kanzlerin frauen
fahren ist als frauen stehen theoretisch
alle türen offen
nur noch idioten waren zu bezweifeln
dass sie dasselbe können wie männer
jetzt müssen die männer noch dasselbe
können wie die frauen nämlich im haus
und bei der kindererziehung dann kommen
wir schon weiter hier im frau media turm
da gibt es natürlich auch die
meilensteine des kampfes für
gleichberechtigung
zum beispiel hier den stern von 1971 wir
haben abgetrieben
damals gab es so ein gemeinsames großes
ziel der frauenbewegung nämlich diesen
paragraf 218 abzuschaffen gibt es heute
auch noch so was wie ein großes einigen
das ziel der frauenbewegung ja dann
legen sie den finger auf den punkt nein
es ist vielfältig aber man muss sagen es
wird zwar in den nachrichten ihren
deutschen gejubelt wenn in argentinien
die fristenlösung eingeführt wird
da wird vergessen dass deutschland bis
heute nicht die fristenlösung hat frauen
haben 50 jahre nachdem stern in
deutschland haben sie in frankreich in
italien überall haben sie das recht in
den ersten drei monaten abzutreiben
nicht in deutschland da müssen sie doch
bitte bitte bitte
und die erlaubnis haben und wir wissen
aus den letzten jahren welchen ärger
emanzipierte ersten erster bekommen die
anbieten medizinisch perfekt und und
gefahrenfrei den frauen zu helfen
nein die front ist jetzt sehr breit und
es gibt fortschritte und rückschritte
zugleich das ist ja immer so wo große
fortschritte sind sind rückschläge
einerseits scheint die
gleichberechtigung selbstverständlich zu
sein
andererseits ist sowas wie
schlankheitswahn und schönheits waren
tobt schlimmer für frauen denn je zuvor
also zum beispiel die hunger sucht ja
ist ja ist sich die gefährlichste sucht
für frauen überhaupt schlimmer als
drogen usw
und jedes zehnte starb daran ist müssen
sich mal überlegen in einem land des
überflusses verhungern die frauen um
perfekt soja über das frauenbild von von
jungen frauen möchte ich gleich mit
ihnen noch kurz kurz noch ein element
aus dem blick zurück
da gab es zwei fernsehduelle die einem
sofort in den sinn kommen 1975 mit
esther vilar und 2001 mit verona
feldbusch wie sie damals noch schauen
schauen wir uns mal kurz sagen
vorher möchte ich aber noch eins fragen
wie kommen sie eigentlich persönlich
dazu diese bücher zu schreiben wie man
sie stehen ja nun ganz allein damit sind
ein rufer in der wüste sie sagen
plötzlich alles ist umgekehrt
und sie sagen genau das gegenteil von
dem was andere sagen oder die ansagen
nun gar nichts und haben keine rechte
meinung wie kommen sie was hat sie
überhaupt motiviert zu sagen frauen sind
dummen frauen können müssen die beine
auseinander halten frauen haben keinen
ehrgeiz wie kommen sie zu dieser
frauenverachtung unter dieser männer
verherrlichung über den quatsch nicht
länger anhören kann denn sie und ihre
genossinnen in der öffentlichkeit
vertreiben den katja den unsinn was
erzähle ich dir von unsinn erzählen dann
doch mal zum beispiel dass frauen
unterdrückt ziehen es gibt überhaupt
keinen solchen geführtes leuten und da
gibt es nicht nur ein einziges das
problem ist für junge frau sie sprechen
aber sie müssen einfach mal so richtig
gar nicht mich sich zwei verschiedenen
sie sprechen immer für alle frauen das
problem ist dass junge frauen das
problem ist dass die frau das wissen sie
sie sind eine ehrliche sogar mit ihren
ein bisschen einfach nicht alle springen
ein bisschen kann man schon mal über
seine haut willkommen
[Applaus]
hier weil meine haut rausgucken und auch
ein bisschen wissen was in der welt los
und ja ich sage ihnen mal eine zahl die
sehr ernst zu nehmen ist ganz seriöse
untersuchungen haben gezeigt dass
aktuelle untersuchungen dass drei von
vier jungen frauen heute in deutschland
die zwischen 14 und 19 sind unsicher
sind mit ihrem aussehen und dass sie
sich hässlich finden sollen sich schon
unheimlich umhängen wie sie alles in
ordnung
4 prozent so staffel niveau aber ich
würde uns filmrechte sendung wünschen
dass er darauf nicht bleiben ja das
waren ja jeweils zwei welten dieser
aufeinander geprallt sind man man hat
den eindruck dass da so ein richtiges
gespräch gar nicht stattfinden konnte
warum haben sie sich trotzdem auf diese
duelle wie das ja hieß eingelassen naja
das eine ist 20 jahre her dass andere 45
jahre interessant dass das soli menschen
noch heute beschäftigt man sieht ja bei
wlan dass ich da sehr ernst bin und das
hat einfach den grund dass dieses buch
benutzt wurde gegen frauen das ich
gespürt habe die atmosphäre im land als
ich zurückkam aus frankreich das die
frauen darüber sehr gekränkt waren und
dass sowohl die männer am stammtisch wie
die in den redaktionen sagten stellt ihr
euch den laden hier guck mal wieder ist
auch eine frau und so das war natürlich
von ihr 1 1 propaganda-trick das war
natürlich grunde eine satire dieses buch
das konnte ja nicht ernst gemeint sein
das sieht man aber trotzdem hat es die
frauen verletzt und dadurch dass ich das
so ernst genommen habe und versucht habe
ernsthaft mit frau villa zu reden
dadurch haben sich glaube ich wirklich
man kann sagen millionen frauen
identifiziert und sind auch viele männer
hellhörig geworden und dadurch hat diese
sendung so geschichte gemacht also der
erst große öffentliche konflikte
geschlechter konflikt interessanterweise
hat stattgefunden zwischen zwei frauen
und das duell mit grüner punkt ja das
sieht man ja das geht schon mehr auf den
körper da wird weniger argumentiert
da habe ich lange gezögert aber da habe
ich dann dasselbe gesehen dass das vor
allem junge frauen darum gehe ich auf
die jungen frauen einen g ein dass sie
das sehr beschäftigt dieses frauenbild
verona pooth ist ja ein werbeprodukte
ist ja maßgeschneidert und nicht auf den
fotos die sind natürlich alle bearbeitet
und so sieht kein lebendiger mensch aus
aber wenn dann die jungen frauen meinen
so müsste man aussehen um erfolg bei
männern zu haben
dann wird es heikel ja und ich fand fand
ich interessant danach da lege ich mir
auch nicht die tasche gab es eine
unheimliche kluft zwischen der reaktion
der menschen die mich monatelang auf der
straße von der anderen straßenseite
hallo vater was ich ihnen noch sagen
wollte und einigen medien und das
bemerkenswerte ist bei den menschen
haben mich am stärksten jüngere männer
angesprochen denn die sind es auch leid
dass man ihnen unterstellt dass sie so
ein frauenbild haben also dass sie nur
so gut dass frauen nur so dumm kexel
sonst so ansprechen und dem tiefen
ausschnitt hatte und sie für so ein
bisschen
wir wollen es ganz offen sagen blöd
verkauft und manipuliert und ich stehe
natürlich für das gegenteil ich stehe
für ein menschenbild in dem sich frauen
und männer gleich gegenüber treten und
sich in die augen gucken und nicht immer
nur auf den hintern
wie sehen sie denn das wie junge frauen
heute ihre frauen rolle interpretieren
es ist eine ungeheure vielfalt es gibt
alles es gibt ja auch nicht die junge
frau und die rolle
man hat heute große möglichkeiten ja man
kann in arbeits buchsen und stiefelchen
loslaufen und sagen ist mir alles egal
oder
ich will automechanikerin werden oder
ich will ins all fliegen usw
gleichzeitig also es gibt eigentlich
zwei strömungen
es gibt diese offizielle behauptung der
gleichberechtigung wir haben doch gar
keine probleme mehr
und drunter wird den jungen frauen
sozusagen und versucht man ihnen die
beine wegzuschlagen zu sagen ja bist du
denn auch schlank genug bist du denn
auch hübsch genug studie auch dieses und
jenes also das frauenbild heute das zum
teil propagiert wird ist ja wird dort
und rückständiger als die 50er jahre
es ist sehr widersprüchlich eine junge
frau scheint die wahl zu haben
gleichzeitig muss sie sich durch diesen
dschungel bewegen
ich will jetzt nicht alle youtube rinnen
über einen kamm scheren aber wenn man
das mal als als beleg oder spiegel der
gesellschaft nimmt von kim kardashian
bis bibis beauty palace das ist ja
deutlich mehr verona pooth als er ist
alles schwarz aber natürlich aber das
ist ja der markt ja da treten ja nicht
alle menschen auf sondern damit dass
verkauft da wird dass diese frauen sind
produkt trägerinnen und es gibt ja
diesen fiesen trick den haben früher die
kirchen stärker angewandt jetzt zu dass
die werbung wenn man menschen ein
schlechtes gewissen macht sie
verunsichert dann kann man ihnen alles
einreden den alles verkaufen
es geht hier um verkaufen ja es gibt die
youtuber rinnen und es gibt diese dame
auf dem cover der aktuellen ma das ist
die vize-präsidentin austin usa camilla
harris sein vorbild ist eben gerade
deswegen auch so wichtig ja das ist doch
großartig ich meine für die frauen in
der ganzen welt und für die farbigen
trauen der ganzen welt am tag ihrer
ihres sieges hat mich meine algerische
freundin angerufen und war außer sich
vor freude
da identifizieren sich alle frauen mit
und ich habe mir auch die vereinigung
angeschaut und fand natürlich sie sie
ist so ganz lebendig und gelassen
großartig der heraus gefällt mir auch
ist differenziert und natürlich haben
wir alles gesehen was wir erhofft haben
auch die farbigen frauen und die lopez
spricht spanisch und lady gaga ist
ausgeflippt und darf trotzdem und so
weiter kämpft ja auch gegen sexuellen
missbrauch von kindern
und sehr bemerkenswert fand ich am
schluss diesen cowboy der anscheinend in
amerika sehr berühmt ist mehr platten
verkauft hat als elvis presley und der
dann also der klassische weiße mann und
anreger unsere probleme
republikaner und der dann im märchen
grace gesungen hat so muss das sein
wir wollen keine spaltung weder zwischen
frauen und männern noch zwischen weißen
und kallert noch zwischen dumm und
schlauen man muss sich jetzt die hand
reichen vor allem in diesen so zerrissen
und gequälten land jetzt und dann nehmen
wir auch die alten weiß männer mit das
ist ja freundlich erhöhen
nochmal oft die ema zu sprechen ich
hoffe ich darf das sagen sie sind 78
jahre alt nach wie vor chefredakteurin
und herausgeberin der immer könnte immer
ohne sie nicht existieren
das weiß ich nicht aber da ich das alter
des neuen präsidenten von amerika habe
mache ich mir da erst mal keine sorgen
wenn der sich die ganze welt zutraut
oder vielmehr amerika so die welt macht
dann traue ich mir schon die immer
weiter zu und ich glaube meine
kolleginnen freuen sich auch dass ich da
bin
einen satz von ihnen habe ich gehört der
mich eigentlich ziemlich traurig
gestimmt hat und der heißt wenn ich
mutter also sie wendig mutter geworden
wäre dann hätte es die immer nicht
gegeben ist das wirklich so entweder
mutter oder immer für meine generation
auf jeden fall
ich meine man darf nicht vergessen ich
habe wie immer 1976 gegründet und das
war doch über sehr sehr viele jahre
quasi ein 24 stunden job
am anfang habe ich ja noch so einen
kleinen aufbau über der redaktion
gewohnt tag und nacht und also wenn man
überhaupt natürlich wenn man ein blatt
macht zu dürfen nicht vergessen die ema
ist das einzige journalistisch im
magazin das seit jahrzehnten unabhängig
ist hinter mir steht keine partei steht
kein konzern steht niemand wir müssen
das geld verdienen das wir ausgeben für
die gehälter für den druck und das tun
wir auch die einzigen von denen wir
abhängen sind unsere leserinnen und
leser heißt sie müssen einen blatt
machen dass die menschen lesen wollen
das spaß macht auch
es kämpft usw also das ist schon ein
sehr rund um job gewesen und ist es noch
jemand wie ich hat natürlich dafür
gekämpft und ich tue das noch dass die
frauen beides tun können dass sie einen
beruf mit leidenschaft haben können das
privileg haben ja nicht viele oder
überhaupt einen beruf und gleichzeitig
kinder und es ist ein system jetzt heute
geht das heute kind und karriere im es
immer noch schwer es ist besser geworden
aber es ist immer noch schwer
ich sehe das an meiner kollegin der ema
redakteurin die zwei kleine kinder hat
die macht das blatt mit leidenschaft die
macht beides aber es klingt manchmal
wenn man muss dann gucken mensch jetzt
gerade in kronau zeiten wie machen wir
das und nein die anleger muss aber jetzt
um 6 gehen die kinder usw
volles verständnis und wir alle
versuchen das und kräften zu
unterstützen
aber es wird manchmal eng die umstände
sind eben wir haben immer noch keine
ausreichenden ganztagsschulen ganzes
kindergärten usw und die kernfamilie ist
natürlich auch nicht das ideale eine
afrikanerin hat mal gesagt man braucht
ein ganzes dorf um ein kind zu erziehen
und inwieweit würde denn jetzt an eine
frauenquote etwas an diesem problem
ändern oder was nützen
es ist eigentlich jetzt sag ich was man
wird mich hoffentlich nicht einigen
es ist eigentlich nicht die quote finde
ich was wir brauchen frauen haben in
relation zu männern auch in unserer
gesellschaft eine strukturelle
benachteiligung da können wir alle
etappen durchgehen und die gibt es immer
noch es gibt auch noch den blick auf die
frau der ganz anders ist als ob der mann
und deswegen muss es eine strukturelle
förderung geben man muss sich den ganzen
lebenslauf von frauen anschauen und muss
sagen moment da müssen wir aber helfen
da müssen wir aber schieben da müssen
wir mehr möglichkeiten geben
dann kommen die tüchtigen und
engagierten frauen voran und auch die
tüchtigen und engagierte männer nehmen
sie nur mal die familienpause ich meine
in westdeutschland nicht in
ostdeutschland wo die frauen
berufstätiger waren
steuern frauen die geschieden sind oder
ihren mann verloren haben oder nie einen
hatten auf eine dramatische altersarmut
zu
das sind renten damit können sie nicht
leben und nicht sterben warum nicht weil
die frauen faul waren sondern weil die
weit meiste arbeit das analysiere ich
auch in meinem buch so genaue zahlen
weil die meiste arbeit die sie leisten
gratisarbeit ist weil sie es sind die
immer noch den löwenanteil von haus und
kindern auf den armen haben
ich sag immer frauen haben erst dann
gleiche chancen wenn ein chef der ein
mann ihm sozusagen im sogenannten
familien gründungs alter anstellt ja
wenn dieser chef den jungen mann genauso
nachdenklich anguckt und sagt sagen sie
mal wollen sie kinder wenn das für ein
mann dasselbe bedeutet wie für eine frau
ich bin ja eigentlich für eine 30
stunden woche für männer wie frauen im
kleinkindalter also unter 63 stunden
kann ich natürlich nicht die ema machen
aber und dann können sich beide das
teilen wenn es soweit ist dass die
männer die hälfte des hauses tragen
dann können frauen auch die häfele welt
schultern
es gibt noch ein thema das sie seit
vielen jahren beschäftigt konkret glaube
ich seit 1979 kommen
die macht im iran übernommen hat das ist
der islam oder besser vielleicht der
islamismus warum müssen die frauen den
islamismus fürchten
ich meine müssen wir ja noch mal einen
fernseher anschalten um zu sehen wie es
millionen frauen in den islamistisch
beherrschten ländern geht das sind ja
nicht die da unter ihren büchern entlang
stolpern die keine gleichen bürgerrechte
haben wo gewalt länder kulturen und
länder in denen gewalt gegen kinder und
frauen selbstverständlich ist also ich
schilder das ja im lebenswerk diesen
zweiten teil meiner autobiografie gucken
china ich das ja sehr genau was sich da
im iran 79 erlebt habe wie das gleich
los ging die völlige entrechtung der
frauen wie zurück geprügelt wurden ins
haus und wie dann der politisierte islam
sozusagen die schritt für schritt bis in
unsere metropolen gekommen ist ich muss
das immer wieder sagen obwohl ich es
noch nie anders gesagt habe ich rede
hier nicht vom islam
ich rede nicht vom glauben ich bin für
absolute glaubensfreiheit und so wenig
wie ich die bibel zitieren in der auch
einiges problematische steht zitiere ich
den koran mit geht es ausschließlich um
diese geiselnahme des glaubens islam um
die um die funktionalisierung des islams
durch eine politische ideologie die wir
heute ist ein business nennen oder dem
politischen islam und das ist eine
ideologie die anstrebt die abschaffung
der demokratie und des rechtsstaats und
die einführung des gottesstaates und der
scharia gut dass wir das nicht wollen
sollte klar sein
also wir können nicht hinter 200 jahre
aufklärung und frauen emanzipation
zurückfallen in unseren ländern leider
nicht in allen anderen gilt
gleichberechtigung der frauen gilt der
rechtsstaat und jeder der das sich
akzeptiert der gehört nicht zu uns das
ist völlig egal ob er gläubig ist und
was er glaubt auf ein christ oder jude
oder muslim die glaubensfrage ist das
nicht es ist eine politische frage
diese glasklare position diese da
einnehmen gegen den islamismus der hat
ihn ja auch in den eigenen reihen sehr
viel ärger eingebracht es gibt nicht
wenige die werfen ihnen vor das ist
rassismus hast ja das schwarze ja ja ja
das ist jetzt so eine mode in manchen
teilen
der linken oder auch in einigen weil
manche feministinnen dass wenn man dem
politischen islam kritisiert und die
auswüchse und die provokationen dass man
sofort als islamophob oder rassistisch
bezeichnet wird das muss man in kauf
nehmen
das ist einfach der versuch der
verhinderung der kritik des politischen
islam wir haben das ja silvester 2015
hier in köln gesehen dass es ja eine
schlüsselszene bis heute ich werde bis
heute im ausland bis heute fünf jahre
danach überall darauf angesprochen da
haben 2000 jüngere männer versucht
sozusagen frauen aus dem öffentlichen
raum zu übertreiben so wie sie es seit
jahrzehnten in ihren ländern tun in
kairo in algier iran und irak sowie so
danach gab es über 600 anzeigen wegen
sexueller gewalt bis hin zur
vergewaltigung und das hat man ja manche
kreise versucht zunächst zu vertuschen
aber witzig weil sie gesagt haben das
darf man doch nicht sagen das ist dann
rassismus moment mal
es ist rassismus zugezogene anders zu
behandeln als die eigenen männer
wenn unsere eigene männer vergewaltigen
dann schreiben wir ja auch ganz laut und
feministin wie ich tun das seit 50
jahren
wenn jetzt männer kommen aus ländern wo
das ihr recht ist und man ihn nicht
beibringt dass das hier nicht geht dass
hier umdenken müssen dass sie hier
frauen als menschen zu behandeln haben
dann finde ich vergeht man sich auch an
diesen männern will man gibt ja diesen
männern nicht die chance die tausende
von kilometern die sie mit den füßen
zurückgelegt haben auch im kopf
zurückzulegen das hat kann er dauert der
algeria der denn der mit dem ich auch
zusammenarbeite mal so schön gesagt sie
haben ihr neues buch erwähnt lebenswerk
blicken sie zurück auf 50 jahre kampf
für gleichberechtigung sie geben aber
auch ein paar einblicke in die private
die persönliche alice schwarzer ich
fange mal mit dem an was schief gelaufen
ist wie sehr hat es sie geärgert dass
sie ihren guten ruf zumindest beschädigt
haben durch die steuerhinterziehung
aber natürlich hat mich das geärgert
aber natürlich ist es war etwas völlig
überflüssiges ich hab die zinsen eines
schweizer kontos nicht nicht versteuert
aus dummheit natürlich sehr ärgerlich
und das kann man erklären muss man aber
nicht erklären
dafür kann man sich nur entschuldigen
nur ich denke es ist dann doch relativ
kleine episode und es hat vor allem
keine politische bedeutung
wir sind auch einige sehr interessante
fotos drin versehen wir sie hiermit
simon deborah und schoss so fotos
erwarte ich in einem buch von alice
schwarzer
da gibt es aber auch diese fotos das
sehen wir sie hier im minirock alles so
um die 1970 herum und hier mit ihrem
langjährigen lebensgefährten prolog das
gibt also auch die alice schwarzer die
designerklamotten liebt und männer liegt
mir sicher ich meine ich bin ja mein
mann mein sozialer ein sozialer vater
war ja ein mann mein großvater der hat
mich aufgezogen ich bin ja nicht von
einer frau gewickelt und ernährt worden
sondern von einem mann
und da liegt es nahe dass man irgendwie
ein gewisses grundvertrauen in männer
hat und wenn die nicht so nett sind wie
der papa wie ich den großvater nannte
dann sagt man was soll denn das
das kann eigentlich seien die könnte
auch anders sein wir haben auch noch
diese fotos das zeigt sie zusammen
die heutige lebensgefährtin und ehefrau
bettina flitner sie haben vor zwei
jahren geheiratet sind aber schon seit
30 jahren zusammen warum diese späte
entscheidung pro jahr weil das doch
einige dinge klarer macht und man ist
auch nicht da muss ich immer höchst und
sagen da habe ich ihn verstehen sondern
nur wissen wir welcher art diese
beziehung ist und ich denke nach 35
jahren kann man das auch mal riskieren
ich habe ältere äußerungen von ihnen
gefunden haben wir sich als ihre gegner
das sich im prinzip auch deswegen war es
auch für mich durchaus an etwas
komplizierter schritt das heißt ich bin
nicht an sich gegen die ehe
ich habe als feministin eine ehe
kritisiert die frauen entrechtet hat
nicht zuletzt und vor allem wie er
feministinnen haben dafür gesorgt dass
das nicht mehr so ist
heute gibt es nur noch sehr wenige
rechtliche probleme im zusammenhang mit
der ehe zum beispiel das steuer
splitting usw oder die andere
steuerklasse die verheerende frauen
benachteiligt schon ein wichtiges
kapitel aber ansonsten dürfen frauen ihr
eigenes konto haben sie dürfen
berufstätig sein der mann ist nicht mehr
familienvorstand ich habe also nichts
mehr gegen eine gleichberechtigte nur
noch gegen diese kleinen missstände und
ich denke manchmal ehrlich gesagt sogar
auch wenn kinder da sind auch soll das
muss jeder für sich entscheiden
ist es schafft es klare verhältnisse und
größere verbindlichkeiten ich ganz
ehrlich gesagt es interessiert mich
sowieso gar nicht den menschen
persönlich etwas vorzuschreiben
ich finde das leben ist kompliziert
genug und man wurschtelt sich dadurch
und wenn man das mit anstand schafft und
auf die lebensfreude dich verliert und
vielleicht sogar noch über sich über die
eigenen interessen hinaus sich ein wenig
für die welt engagiert und die menschen
nehmen an dann ist das schon sehr habe
ich bin jemand der strukturen und
sachverhalte kritisiert aber nicht
jemand der menschen irgendwas
vorschreiben will das war für mich
persönlich heute mit alice schwarzer
herzlichen dank herzlichen dank an sie
zu hause und bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]